[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler free review
of it chapter 2 now if you've already
seen the movie you can check out I also
have a spoiler review of each chapter -
so jumping into this I love the first it
I loved it so much that I actually read
the full book this summer and if you
don't know it chapter 2 in a chapter
when the movies are all in one big book
that's 1,200 pages long by Stephen King
and I was actually very disappointed
with the book after loving the first
movie when I realized was wow all the
really good stuff from this book are in
that first movie and that made me worry
about the second movie cuz I was like
well they kind of left a lot of the
sludge here and I wonder how they're
gonna address that and they just brought
us the sludge and it was disappointing
like it was with the book for me
unfortunately the adult storylines in
the book are not as interesting as these
kids storylines and the movie has to now
eat its cake and suffer through that
because then clearly made a decision for
the first movie to have the best stuff
in it it really didn't make the movie a
hit it made it more exciting based off a
book that could be very slow at times
and now they made a sequel and now they
had to figure out okay well how are we
gonna kind of get through this weaker
material and it really just didn't
figure it out it was weak the CGI in
here is disappointingly bad especially
for a big studio like Warner Brothers
producing this because the first one was
such a big hit so okay put all the money
into this and it didn't have that type
of quality another thing was there was
you'll see there's de-aging effects put
on the kids and flashbacks which just
seems very weird and also cheap in the
way they did it makes you feel like
watching your video game it takes you
out of it a bit it's also not that's
scary
but the first one wasn't either but that
first one had a lot of creepiness to it
and an eerie vibe throughout and this
just felt corny cheesy the timing was
off with the jumps you knew and
everything's coming so please prepare to
be disappointed in that and even I hate
to say it but bill skarsgård
here felt not as in sync with himself as
he was in the first movie it just didn't
feel as consistent there was just weird
moments with him I think the whole movie
felt like that I think Bill Hader did
amazing he just saw a job but he's
getting a little too much love like
people are saying it's Oscar or they I
don't think that role Bilt's that way I
thought he just was really good that was
perfectly cast the movie especially the
actor who plays Mike Hanlon the one who
plays ed he's pretty good too and they
look just like their kid counterparts
but I did not like the casting of James
McAvoy and Jessica Chastain the two
biggest stars here Jessica Chastain does
not bring the charm that Beverly has at
all she plays Jessica Chastain in this
movie James McAvoy has a weird thing
where he just was miscast he's always a
great actor to me he always gives it his
all but he doesn't translate well from
the kid of Bill feels like a different
person
especially when they're actually in
scenes together with flashbacks and I
think that he has his voice from split
that voice slips in here a lot and it
feels so unnecessary and off to put in
here need to go to the stutter but again
just a miscast he's not bill to me at
all where everyone else was and Jessica
Chastain really bad at the screaming
here again scream queen talent is very
underrated in Hollywood it is a skill
and she did not do that well it just
what you stand by it
and it just felt lazy so that was a
problem it is a mess of a movie and it
just feels like it's trying to get
through it all and get it over with and
there's no room for things to breathe
and somehow it's one of the slowest
movies ever seen which is just
impressive in its own right and I really
thought this movie was gonna be at least
good but it was bad and I think that it
has moments of trying to do the Marvel
humor thing which every movie has to do
now for some reason because they see
it's a formula and people go see it for
that but I just wish it stayed in its
own ballpark and did will work from the
first movie you keep it's telling it was
a huge hit why would you try to now
emulate other big blockbusters I just do
not make sense of any of this especially
you with some of the music choices they
do the humor falls flat a lot that was
really discipline
and there's no suspense here there's no
tension I did not feel it anywhere
that's a problem with the directing for
sure but again they're working with some
really weak book material in my opinion
and they really also just didn't hold
their weight either directing writing
some acting here and there but some of
the editing was good some of the other
thing was sharp
I like the transitions they used to go
from time periods but overall not gonna
spoil anything but man you gotta lower
your expectations down a lot and me even
just lowering my expectations which they
were going to see smoothie I was excited
as hell a little the first one but I
knew what I read in the book and I knew
it I was ready to see but I was like
maybe they can at least make it decent
see what they're doing here and make it
entertaining but they just did not and
they just save your money it's a two
hour 45 minute movie do not see in
theaters trust me it is uh not even
close to the first one and it's not what
you're expecting either as just a movie
it's if you're there for comedy it's not
funny if you're there for har it's not
scary if you're there for creepiness
eeriness and heart which the first one
had you can say all those are not in
this movie so it's a mess it's a bad
movie so I'm giving it a five point five
wait till it comes out on HBO or Netflix
and once you do see the movie definitely
check out my spoiler review maybe we'll
see eye to eye or maybe you love it who
knows and let me know and below if you
plan on seeing it well your thoughts on
ER what you're expecting I'd love to
hear that and please subscribe to my
channel you don't miss it one of my
reviews I do movie TV reviews and I do
celebrity interviews as well please
follow me at Steve rd1 on Twitter and
screen for more of me and I'll see you
next time